we're installing sensors underneath
everyone's desks they detect when a
workspace is occupied and report that
data back to us I think that feels a
little invasive don't worry data on its
own is just a harmless object like a
sharp rock I don't like the idea of the
company knowing every time I go to the
bathroom oh the two of you will not have
desk sensors I withdraw my objection but
we do want you to be the face of this
initiative this is a chance for you to
step into a management role right now
your co-workers see you as friends
yeah this will show them that you're in
charge like the boys in blue or the man
upstairs and if you get any guff and you
will receive golf just remind everyone
that Hampton Deville is pro data and to
be anti desk sensor is to be anti data
and therefore anti Hampton Deville and
if anyone has any questions we're happy
to have a friendly combo oh yes Ted how
long can we be away from our desks
without being punished great question
Ted no one is being punished we're just
collecting data but you might want to
cut down on those bathroom breaks or you
will be punished what gives you two sis
white men the right to keep track of
every time I go to the bathroom first of
all I'm not white I'm Jewish and I have
walked a very difficult road second what
gives us the right is where your
superiors and above the law but we're
also your friends and the same as all of
you do you two have death sensors great
question Jessica no but we're sorry this
is like 1984 right and you guys are big
brother this is nothing like 1984 I bet
you've never even read 1984 oh I've read
1984 and it was a page-turner I
loved it the point is we're gonna be
watching me at all times so think of us
as God but remember God loves you so
much and he's still a cool guy that you
get a beer with after work wrong god is
bad and vengeful and doesn't exist now
you might want to get back to your desks
because those sensors are turning on
right about now
sorry about this guy's
it's good though this is a good thing
you